[Applause]
olive oil to bring you another delicious
recipe yes we are oh I got a good one
for you all right well you know I've
been on a real Health Journey for a long
time you know lost 60 pounds holding it
strong I'm in the fight so good
I discovered the Mediterranean diet and
it's much more of a like a style of
eating than a restrictive diet and guess
what olive oil is one of the key
ingredients so today I'm making you a
roasted spatchcock chicken with a side
of potatoes and grilled veggies it is a
good living recipe with Mediterranean
flavors straight from the Olive Grove
and I'm going to show you how I made it
right now have you ever spatched cocked
a chicken funny enough I have and if you
don't know what this is they just remove
the spine and then flip it over and sort
of just cool like that and it flattens
out so I took one of those and I
marinated this is some Bertolli extra
virgin olive oil I have some herbs in
here I rubbed it all over the chicken
and Under the Skin and then I put this
chicken skin side down in this hot pan
with some we're totally cooking olive
oil it has a higher burning point and I
crisp up that skin then I take it out
and I just set it aside for a second I
know it looks good then I'm gonna put
we're gonna put just a little more olive
oil Bertolli in here in the pan and then
I've got some potatoes and and onions
that's that's my favorite part listen to
that Sizzle oh
[Applause]
and just let those potatoes fry okay
don't worry about it Bertolli can take
the heat all right I'll leave it alone
okay
all right what's next so once these
onions sort of caramelize and potatoes
get some texture on it we're going to
take our friend the chicken and put him
back on here but this time with the skin
Side Up got it yes okay and then I'm
gonna put this juice in here because
hello all of that olive oil look at that
herbs beautiful then I'm gonna put this
just back in the oven for how long what
time 4 25 about 30 40 minutes until you
can check the temperature on the inside
of the chickens about when you've got to
be 165. now meanwhile I have some
veggies over here and some hot Grill
pans yes I'm gonna just put some
Bertolli extra virgin olive oil on your
veggies on the veggies yes and then do
some salt and pepper and toss them
around so then we're just going to put
them on our grill pan all right here we
go the Mediterranean lifestyle is about
slowing down like look what we're doing
now we're hanging out together
a little grilling broth so I'm very
happy with the look of my grill pan so
now what well look we're starting to get
Little Grill lines and vegetables
especially when you put some Bertolli
olive oil on that Grill brings out the
sweetness in every vegetable so you
think you know a zucchini Grill it girl
Grill it all right look at this this is
the finished product
but I'm not done yet
well the last step is just drizzle some
of that over because that's the flavor
Power Punch that's going to get you I'm
going straight in for the potato okay do
it go in
oh my God yeah I'm gonna try this
chicken
okay
see on a personal note I have to say
that I love Bertolli because it's what
my dad used on his skin and he was so
passionate about this brand and when I
found out we were working with them it
made me so emotional because it just is
my dad and I love bear totally and I'm
so glad they're doing this with that I
love them but I'm so glad that you could
teach us about health and wellness Rossi
because you have never looked better and
you you're just such an inspiration well
we are sending our audience home with
better Foley extra virgin olive oil to
join in on the Mediterranean lifestyle
and we'd love for you to visit our
website for the full or recipe so enjoy
something very near and dear to my heart
and something so good for you too thank
you Bertoli you're gonna love it all
right we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]